in 1937 Amelia Earhart was one of the
most famous women on the planet the last
decade she had been uh pending
stereotypes smashing records and
establishing herself as an international
role model as she set off for her
greatest adventure around the world
excursion the whole world was watching
then suddenly she was gone just
disappeared in this week's biographic
s-- we delve into the marvelous and the
mysterious life and the death of Amelia
Earhart Amelia Earhart was born on July
the 24th 1897 in Atchison Kansas she was
the older of two daughters - Edwin and
Amy with sister Muriel being two years
younger Edward Stanton Earhart was a
talented lawyer who worked for the
railways but his career was blighted by
an addiction to alcohol Amelia was named
after her maternal grandmother Milly
Otis Milly and Amelia's grandfather
Alfred actually took the girl in and she
lived with them during the school year
in Atchison from the ages of three to
eleven during the holidays she went to
live with her parents in Kansas City
Amelia attended a private college
preparatory school until she was ready
for high school
becoming an avid reader young Amelia
spent many long hours devouring books of
every sort even though she spent most of
the year away from him Amelia adored her
witty and well-educated father Edwin
woods entertained the girls and their
friends with Western thrillers complete
with bandits Indians Cowboys and other
made-up characters Amelia marveled over
his command of the English language and
one letter he addressed her as dear
parallelepipeds on and she rushed to
find a dictionary to discover the words
meaning
despite his brilliance as a wordsmith
Edwin was not so lucky when it came to
financial matters as a railroad lawyer
he never really applied himself
preferring rather to spend his time
coming up with inventions that would
make his fortune in 1903 he designed a
device to hold signal flags on the ends
of trains full of enthusiasm he traveled
to washington d.c to fill his plans with
the Patent Office after two frustrating
days he read back to Amelia's mother
that a man from Colorado had filed a
patent on an identical holder two years
ago this news is a terrible blow because
I had been counting on receiving several
hundred dollars from the railroad for my
flag holder were still the money that
Edwin had been counting on was earmarked
to pay the family's property taxes in
order to pay the tax bill he had to sell
a collection of valuable law books that
have been given to him by his father in
law judge Otis
the judge was furious that his
son-in-law had done these things and a
year later when Edwin took his wife and
two girls for a week-long trip to the
World's Fair in San Louis the judge
considered the trip an extravagant waste
of money and further proof of Edwin's
spendthrift habits despite our
grandfather's reservations Amelia loved
the trip as she enthusiastically rushed
with her sister around the 1,500
buildings and twelve palaces all lit by
the still relatively new phenomenon of
electricity in her autobiography the
funovits published in 1932 amelia
pinpointed three important threads that
attracted her to aviation and interest
in mechanic's the many railroad trips
she took with her father and her love of
experimentation with sport and games as
a railroad claims agent Edwin was able
to take his family on trips all over the
country her travels developed an Amelia
a deep-seated desire to see more and
more of the world at large when Amelia
wasn't travelling she spent hours
sitting with her cousins Lucy and
Catherine chalice looking over maps of
faraway places and dreaming of overseas
excursions from the beginning the future
aviatrix was a daredevil who acted as if
she was immune to danger she was
attracted to every type of sport but she
chafed under the societal stereotypes of
the day which limited girls to reading
sewing and cooking she was lucky that
she had parents who encouraged her
tastes for boys pursuits and allowed her
and her sister to dress in dark blue
flannel bloomers gathered up at the
knees for play rather than the customary
dresses and pinafores at school Amelia
was known as Millie she earns good
grades but seemed to be rather in
patience and she didn't worry about the
details of her academic work she would
quite easily solve maths problems in her
head but couldn't be bothered writing
out her working this lack of attention
to detail was a trait that stayed with
Amelia into adulthood it was at the Iowa
State Fair in 1907 that Amelia saw her
first airplane she recalled it as a
thing of rust and wire that didn't
interest her at all
and she wasn't alone
at the time neither automobiles nor
planes were predicted to become a
functional means of transportation in
Amelia stopped living with her
grandparents in Atchison and moved with
her parents to Des Moines Iowa there she
entered public school she did well
academically despite her problems at
home
her parents argued constantly mainly
over money and the constant quarreling
drove her beloved father to the bottle
this was at a time when states across
America were increasingly becoming dry
public displays of drunkenness were a
source of great humiliation as a result
the pitiful public inebriation of Edwin
stanzen Earheart soon became the talk of
the town
the heavy drinking eventually led to
Edwin losing his job at the railway for
over a year he remains out of work
finally securing a menial clerking job
it required that the family moved to
simple Minnesota the departure from Iowa
was a depressing one for the girls but
especially for their long-suffering
mother as they boarded the railroad car
docent Paul she shed tears of
frustration life was tough and simple
with the family barely making ends meet
Edwin's drinking was also still not
under control on one occasion the media
found a bottle of whisky and her
father's suitcase and proceeded to empty
it into the kitchen sink an infuriated
Edwin tried to slap the girl but he
stopped him
the constant moves that her family
undertook during her teen years left
Amelia feeling rootless and insecure but
rather than discussing her problems she
instead focused on her ambitions the
family only stated support for a year
with the drama waiting Edwin in the
claims office of the Burlington railway
they relocated to Springfield Missouri
the move though it was a disaster after
a seven-hour train journey the family
discovered the job had already been
taken for Amy this was the final straw
she demanded a trial separation and took
the two girls to Chicago to stay with
old family friends in Chicago Amelia
shoulder responsibility for her mother
and sister as head of the household her
behavior and her appearance changed
dramatically although she attended Hyde
Park the best public high school in
Chicago she did not participate in any
of the numerous clubs that the school
offered nor did she play any of the
sports that she so loved she now
referred to herself as AE and isolated
herself from her fellow students she
refused to attends the senior banquet
and graduation ceremony a senior
yearbook photo caption read the girl in
brown who walks alone by the fall of
1915 though things had improved in the
Earhart marriage Edwin had stopped
drinking and the family had reunited in
Kansas City for the next year Amelia did
not attend school but spent her time
acting as a buffer between her parents
and hoping to preserve the marriage the
family fortunes took an immediate turn
when Annie received an inheritance she
used some of the funds to send Amelia to
the organs finishing school on the
outskirts of Philadelphia it was there
that Amelia polished her social graces
which would allow her to move with ease
and poise among all segments of society
after she became famous at the age of 19
she was the oldest of the stood
at the finishing school when she entered
in the fall of 1916 while she was there
Amelia's feminist proclivities came to
the fore she kept a newspaper clipping
file of accomplished women any of them
firsts in their fields but she was no
suffragette next to one clipping she
wrote women will gain economic justice
by proving themselves in all lines of
endeavor not by having laws passed for
them over the first semester Christmas
break Amelia returned home while there
she witnessed the ravages of the First
World War
returned soldiers on the street with
missing limbs or had been blinded or had
been otherwise mames she returned to the
finishing school but she felt conflicted
she wrote to her mother I can't bear the
thought of going back to school and
being so useless
Amelia decided to quit the school and
enrolled in a course to join a voluntary
aid detachment a group of civilians who
served as assistant nurses ambulance
drivers and regular nurses after several
months of training sister Amelia as she
was known was posted to Spadina military
hospital on the campus of the University
of Toronto working there until just
before the Armistice in 1918 she cared
for soldiers who had been poisoned by
gas and otherwise injured in the
trenches of the Western Front she also
looks after pilots from the Royal Flying
Corps Canada who had crashed in Europe
it was while tending to these injured
pilots that Amelia became fascinated
with the idea of flying the men would
trade stories about their exploits high
above the grounds nearby was the Royal
Flying Corps Base and the skies were
filled with hundreds of planes buzzing
around civilians were not allowed to fly
in the planes but on her days off Amelia
spent time with the pilots and attended
aerial exhibitions now the hospital job
it was intensely demanding with Amelia
often working 12-hour shifts
she became so worn down that in the
summer of 1918 she came down with
influenza and pneumonia and develops
painful sinusitis as a result of this
she suffered from chronic sinus
infections for the rest of her life
after a period of convalescence with her
mother
Amelia enrolled at Columbia University
studying zoology biology and chemistry
she rented a modest apartment in New
York City at the end of the spring term
though she quit her studies she would
later claim that she had simply decided
against a medical career the reality was
that she lacked the temperament to wade
through years of tertiary study spending
the next year with her parents in Los
Angeles
Malea put her focus on helping them keep
their marriage intact over the course of
that year the now 22 year old amelia
would take her first paying job drive
her first car and fly her first plane
Los Angeles in 1920 was a haven for
pilots it was full of Barnstormers
pilots who stunted in air circuses and
gave rides to often
terrified passengers in December of 1920
Amelia and her father went to an air
rodeo in Long Beach where pilots
performed spins loops and dives amid a
crowd of spectators the next day edwin
paid $10 to give his daughter her first
passenger flight a ten-minute ride over
the Hollywood Hills the moment the plane
left the grounds she knew that she
herself had to fly it was at that moment
that she knew she had found her calling
without telling her parents Amelia
signed up for flying lessons with the
expectation that edwin would cover the
$500 fee but her father had no interest
in his daughter's newfound obsession and
he was forced to find a job as a
telephone clerk in order to fund the
lessons she chose to be instructed by a
female pilot and Nita
Netta snuke after ten hours of lessons
Amelia went solo in 1921 the
exhilarating experience encouraged her
on to achieving her full pilot's license
over the next few months as she
progressed in her lessons Amelia became
an airfield junkie she cropped her long
hair and began wearing breeches boots
and an oil stains leather jacket
despite complaining about the high cost
of lessons she managed to scrape
together the money needed to buy her
first plane this was thanks largely to
her mother's inheritance this plane was
a nester with a 28 foot wingspan indeed
it was the second Esther ever built she
named this plane canary during these
early years Amelia didn't consider
herself a good enough liar to appear in
public events however her humility
didn't preclude a few appearances at air
shows and two attempts at record-setting
in the LA area the press was also
beginning to mention her as one of the
few women pilots in the area by 1923 she
had turned into a confident pilot though
she was not a natural flyer and
struggled throughout her instruction
many men and even some women were better
pilots than Amelia but her persistence
and her bravery set her apart in 1924
Amelia's parents marriage finally ended
in divorce a devastated Amelia saw no
reason to stay in California and she
relocated Boston along with her mother
and her sister the following year she
re-enrolled at Columbia switching to
majoring in engineering but when she
scored a c-minus in algebra she once
again quit her studies she then applied
for it
to MIT that was turned down
[Music]
over the next few years Emilia worked at
a number of menial jobs eventually she
ended up as a social worker at a
settlement house in Boston in 1928 her
three-year hiatus from flying ended when
she agreed to take a seat as a passenger
and log keeper on a flight from New York
to London the plane was a Fokker f73
metre float plane piloted by Wilmer
Stultz
the flight plane took off on the morning
of June the 17th and arrived at Barrie
points in South Wales nearly 21 hours
later despite her role being a minimal
one Amelia was now in the books as the
first woman to fly the North Atlantic
returning to the USA Amelia develops a
close relationship with George Putnam a
New York businessman and former
publisher then nurse when she had
interviewed for a place on the Fokker
Putnam helped her to improve her flying
skills and to embark on a series of
lecture tours intended to promote the
aircraft industry and encourage women to
become pilots over the next few months
she wrote her first autobiography 20
hours 40 minutes about her flight across
the North Atlantic on November the 22nd
1929 Amelia sat a woman's speed record
for a single-engine monoplane the
following year she purchased a Lockheed
Vega executive and in it she broke the
speed record for a course of 100
kilometres Amelia and George Putnam
were married on the 7th of February 1931
over that next year she set and broke
several altitude records on the 20th of
May 1932 she took off from Newfoundlands
in her Vega touching down in a field of
cows in Londonderry Island 15 hours and
30 minutes later she had just become the
first woman to fly solo across the North
Atlantic
[Music]
[Applause]
with her husband's flair for publicity
she quickly became the most famous woman
flyer on the planet Putman build his
wife as lady Lindy capitalizing on the
massive popularity of Charles Lindbergh
amelia was now a fully fledged celebrity
when she made public appearances she
needed police protection
she branched out by designing a range of
clothing that copied her look in January
of 1935 Amelia became the first woman to
fly from Hawaii to California in that
year she also wrote her second biography
the fun of it while continuing a hectic
schedule of lecture tours and public
appearances on July the 20th 1935 Amelia
celebrated her 38th birthday she knew
that she couldn't go on breaking records
forever yet
she still had one more big one to knock
off in fact it was the biggest of them
all and that's of course a flight around
the world to achieve a round-the-world
flight Amelia would need a bigger plane
in early 1936 she purchased a
twin-engine Lockheed 10e Electra a plane
that was the products of the finest
technology available at the time it was
a low-wing monoplane of all-metal
construction with constant speed
propellers powered by two pratt &
whitney wasp
s3 h14 550 horsepower engines the
interior of the plane was modified to
take extra petrol tanks giving a
theoretical range of 4,000 miles at an
altitude of 4,000 feet the plane was
also fitted with one of the very first
Sperry automatic pilots in order to
relieve the physical strain of flying on
Amelia despite this innovation it became
apparent that Amelia would need
navigational assistance to fly across
the Pacific Ocean her navigational
knowledge was rudimentary and so
irish-born navigator Fred Noonan was
recruited for the world-record attempt
Noonan was keen to be involved but there
was one aspect of the navigational set
that he wasn't happy with the only way
the Navigator could reach the pilot was
by crawling along a catwalk over the
intervening fuel tanks a sample system
was devised whereby written messages
could be clipped to the line of a bamboo
fishing pole and passed between them but
this inadequate method impaired the
crucial element of teamwork
the plans route for the round-the-world
flights began in Oakland California with
the first landing place in Honolulu
Hawaii
from there it continued in a westerly
direction taking advantage of prevailing
winds in order to maximize publicity
Putnam required his wife to keep a
detailed diary and post entry stem from
each stop he would edit them so he could
rush out a book as soon as she achieved
the record now the first leg of the
round-the-world flight took off from
Oakland's at 16:30 on March the 17th
1937 the flight to Honolulu was smooth
and uneventful taking 15 hours and 47
minutes the next stop was to be the tiny
American territory of Howland Island
1,800 miles away immediately things went
wrong the plane swung to the right just
after takeoff then grounds looping as
the undercarriage collapsed
fortunately Amelia managed to land
without any injury or fire but the
world-record attempt had to be put on
hold as the plane was crated and sent
back to Lockheed for rebuilding the
rebuilding was completed on May the 17th
efforts were made to reduce the weight
of the plane one of which undoubtedly
contributors to the tragedy that was to
come the trailing aerial which allowed
them to request bearings on 500
kilohertz from ground stations was
removed three days after the rebuilt
Electra was delivered to them Amelia and
Noonan took off from Auckland for the
second time because of seasonal changes
it was decided that this new attempt
would be done in the reverse direction
the first leg was to Miami and then on
to Puerto Rico Venezuela Dutch Guinea
and in early June they flew on to Brazil
the following days were spent servicing
the engines and checking the instruments
the 1,900 mile flight across the South
Atlantic was made on the 7th of June
landing in Dakar Senegal of a journey
across Africa and lasted four days it
was followed by the longest leg of 1950
kilometres to Karachi in India there the
plane was serviced by Imperial Airways
along with members of the British RAF on
June the 17th safely one-two dum dum
near Calcutta landing in the middle of a
torrential rainstorm after a fueling at
Bangkok they flew on to Singapore from
there is on to bang dong in Java here
the Electra developed some kind of
instrument false on the flight to sir a
buyer in East Java the problem re
occurred forcing them back to Bandung
where there were repair facilities On
June the 29th they flew to lie
New Guinea the 1200 mile flight was
completed in 7 hours and 43 minutes so
far the pair had traveled 22,000 miles
the pair must have been extremely tired
by this point but the greatest challenge
it still lay ahead of them and that was
of course crossing the Pacific
[Music]
the next objective was Howland Island
some 2566
miles away the two spends June the 30th
in preparation for the mammoth flight
several witnesses later reported that
Noonan was drinking heavily on this day
and was still doing so in the evening as
Amelia attended a dinner party they took
off at 10 a.m. on July the 2nd
eyewitnesses reported that the electra
lifted off sluggishly sank downwards
toward the sea and then began a very
slow climb to the east and no one never
saw them again the last known position
of the Electra was near the new Khomeini
Islands the last radio message from
Amelia was we must be on you but gas is
running low have been unable to reach
you by radio we are flying at 1,000 feet
the official search efforts to find the
missing plane and its famous occupant
lasted until July the 19th 1937 the air
and sea search by the US Navy and Coast
Guard was the most expensive in US
history
still no physical evidence of the plane
or the remains of Amelia and Noonan were
ever found over the decades the
speculation over what happened to Amelia
Earhart has intensified in 2017 a photo
emerged that purported to show a back
view of Amelia sitting on a pier in the
Marshall Islands however this photo was
debunked when it was proven that it was
actually taken in 1935 two years before
Amelia disappeared then in March of 2018
an anthropology professor at the
University of Tennessee named Richard
chanst argued that bones found on the
islands of nickimja rauru in 1940 were
99% likely to be those of Amelia Earhart
the bones were analyzed in 1941 and
determined to be those of a male Jan's
believes that that analysis was deeply
flawed yes other scientists uphold the
original findings while we may never
know what really happened to Amelia it
appears quite certain there's the
tantalizing mystery of her disappearance
while keep her name in the headlines for
many yes to come so I really hope you
enjoyed that episode of biographic if
you did there's a couple of things you
could do right now one is hit that like
button below also if you want more stuff
like this we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so hit
that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next
do the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
month n thursday won't put out a new
video also if you want to watch
something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching